I'm going to leave the the task of
introducing each of the speakers to my
colleague Henry Jenkins but I do want to
say one thing first one of the speakers
today asked when you need to help me
with the last name again ask when Poona
thought I screwed it up again I'm sorry
you can see his name there it's my Anglo
Saxon weaknesses that make it impossible
for me to say
Indian names I apologize Iceland is a is
a graduate of the MIT program in
comparative media study and to my
knowledge he is the first such graduate
to speak at a communications forum event
so this is a doubly interesting and
exciting moment for those of us in CMS
so I'm Henry Jenkins and I'm gonna be
moderating this discussion sir the title
global media tells us next to nothing
about what we're gonna be talking about
for the next hour next two hours there's
so many theories of globalization out
there so many ways that connects to the
word media so the first thing we're
really going to try to do is get on top
of that for the moment we I think we
might describe it as locally and
nationally specific modes of production
and consumption in a context of global
circulation that is we're gonna be very
interested in a local level the
decisions that get made to produce
content that's gonna see be seen by
audiences around the world and what we
there's national still plays a very
important role in our understanding of
what constitutes global media no sense
of the nation-state disappear but the
the relationship of local media
industries to a global marketplace are
changed profoundly just to give two
examples in the last week that would
sort of point to this the first is that
at least as of Monday afternoon 100
million people have seen Susan Boyles
appearance on Britain's Got Talent
write an extraordinary story just by
point of comparison 37 million people
saw the final episode last season of
America
one of the highest-rated shows on
American television so so far close to
three times the number of people have
downloads Susan Boyles video on YouTube
has watched the high one of the
highest-rated shows an American told
this is a global phenomenon it's worth
and all the fuss that's been made about
Susan Boyle we lose track of the fact
that it's from a television show that's
not commercially available in this
market indeed if people get hooked in
the Susan Boyle story they won't be able
to follow it on broadcast television
although Pirates are already there right
you can go and BitTorrent and see
Britain's Got Talent
easily enough but you're not going to be
able to see it on American networks and
so it says something even when a hundred
million people in the United States our
inch or around the world are interested
in this content there's still borders
and barriers that block entry of
international content into the United
States and we've got to actually think
about that even when we're talking about
commercially produced content in English
language from Great Britain one of our
closest allies the second marker I
wanted to point out is YouTube I
launched a movie channel on in the last
couple of weeks which has the content
organized by genre and one of the genres
they organize content by is foreign film
now what does it mean for YouTube which
operates is globally accessible to have
a category of foreign film who is it
foreign to write you know what what is
how the people aren't going to
understand their experience where one
country is able to produce film that
seemed globally and a scene as America
you know just Hollywood and every other
filmmaking industry in the world gets
labeled as foreign and clumped into the
same genre by a global media company
like YouTube so this points of the
degree to which is a society we're in a
very contradictory state in terms of a
much more greater access to global
content than ever before and not having
developed our conceptual framework to
think about it very well so each of the
speakers today will be talking about
different national contacts different
genres different modes of circulation
but we hope that together they give us a
snapshot of how the media assist a
global media system is beginning to take
shape and what the implications are of
this global this increased but not yet
there so
system of global circulation of media so
that said opening us up we were going to
each of the speakers you're gonna give a
very brief opening comments describing
some of their research and thought in
this area and then we're gonna start
mixing it up with some of the Congress
it caught topics that are on the board
there and eventually open it up to you
to the floor for questions comments
participation which is always the
highlight of any of our communication
forum events so first up is ask us when
Kunta Becca a 2003 graduate of MIT
comparative Media Studies master's
program I'm really proud to have him
there for that reason he studies
globalization cultural industries new
media and media convergence and public
culture he's currently working on a book
that provides an historical and critical
account of ongoing changes in the media
sector in Bombay and examines the
operations of film television and
dot-com companies as they grapple with
the challenges of imagining Bollywood as
a global cultural industry
so for a few days in February 2009
nearly about 3,000 individuals executive
directors producers policy makers
bureaucrats
from all over the world came together
for a number of days in bombay to
celebrate a decade of the globalisation
of Indian film and television and while
this three-day convention organized by
the Federation of Indian Chambers of
Commerce and Industry attracted
participants from a range of industries
there was no doubt that the proceedings
were dominated by this thing that we now
recognize as folly would and over three
days a number of panel sessions tackled
various aspects of change that the film
industry has undergone over the past
decade a decade since the government
officially granted industry status to
cinema and initiated a discourse of
corporatization and of course over these
days there was a lot of disagreement
over what actually bollywood needs to
look like debate about debates about the
merits of Hollywood style organization
and practices versus the family-run and
kinship based model that has defined the
workings of the film industry since the
late 1940s partnerships with Hollywood
studios treaties with organizations like
the UK film Council piracy and so on and
as I wandered from one panel to another
I started just making a list of people
of places of companies of different
kinds of organizations that seem to have
a stake in these discussions of
Bollywood and of the globalisation of
Indian cinema and among the people who
were there was yes Chopra who's the
chairman of chairman of this very
important film committee a stalwart of
the industry and who along with his son
Aditya Chopra is seeking to redefine
Yash Raj Films as a new kind of global
media company there was Karan Johar
another filmmaker who has played a
crucial role in redefining relations
between the Diaspora and and the
filmmaking industry in Bombay and while
this established players in the Bombay
media world made their appearances on
various panels there were other
individuals organisations and companies
that were also involved so to begin with
as you saw the US was a partner country
throughout this convention and the US
commercial service had a very prominent
presence and that little short you saw
of the store
oddly enough for this throughout those
four days there was nobody Manning that
booth it was just this stall of saying
US commercial service by USA and ours
we I never quite figured out who was
behind this why they'd set up the stall
and so on and there were multinational
firm companies and television company
Sony colors which is a Wykeham own
company with which in a year is now the
leading satellite television company and
there was the cafe there was MIPTV of
television sales urging executives from
bombay to travel but there were also
others Shekar Kapur from London a
15-percent delegation from the UK film
council another Hussain who runs a
company called dilly wood which acts as
a mediator for firm companies coming
from Bombay a diasporic entrepreneur who
handles everything from lodging to food
to travel for film crews that travel
here that was angela budd see you on CEO
and co-founder of Desi hits a new
york-based web portal involved in
creating a space for desi remix fusion
music and individuals from Warner
Brothers for Searchlight Disney NBC the
Australian Broadcasting Corporation a
number of venture capitalists and so on
now many while many of the panel
discussions were focused on and they
actually revealed a lot of confusion
conflicts and tensions in the ongoing
kind of negotiations around redefining a
national film industry into what many of
us many people want to call as Bollywood
a global cultural industry one sense
that was very very clearly emerging was
in spite of all these confusions one
thing was clear that the spatial
coordinates of this thing that we called
Bollywood had changed dramatically in
the last 10 to 15 years so the answer to
the question where in the world is
Bollywood or how is the world in
Bollywood would have to be it depends so
here's one possible mapping yeah we can
begin with say in the northern suburbs
of Bombay with Yash Raj Films in the
local voilá complex which is comparable
to perhaps the Burbank area and
California where a number of film and
television companies have their offices
and from here we could slowly move up a
little north to take a look at the film
city a little further north in Goregaon
Mumbai which offers a range of spaces a
range of production options and from
here keeping in mind that the
redefinition of Bollywood spatial
coordinates began to change when
satellite television made an appearance
in India and
1990s we could move to the south of the
city to the offices of MTV and to all
the transnational advertising agencies
and I'm from there maybe all the way to
London where the UK film Council is
based and where people like Shekar
Kapoor are invested in forging stronger
ties with a range of players in Bombay
as well and from here we could then move
to Burbank where companies like Warner
Brothers Disney and Fox Searchlight are
all trying to figure out and their
imaginations and practices are also
caught up in redefining Bombay the
Bombay film industry into Bollywood Inc
but the one thing that I do want to
point out let's not forget that this is
only one possible map and that if we
follow this map we could begin to
develop an understanding of how the
imaginations and practices of state
institutions this was organized by the
National an institution of this federal
government the Federation of Indian
Chambers of Commerce and Industry and we
could also map the imaginations and
practices of different industry
professionals but there are some other
parts of the world which are also
involved in recreating Bollywood's or
reimagining Bollywood geographic reach
so here's another possibility we could
move from the suburbs of Bombay to
Karachi in Pakistan
which is a renowned sort of hub for
media piracy and from there to Dubai
which complicates matters a little bit
more given the city's position as an
important media capital in both
legitimate and illegitimate ways and
from there all the way to Beirut in
Lebanon where distributors as Brian
Larkin has shown us were invested in
circulating volume with firms for over
three decades now and from Lebanon all
the way into Nigeria where the
circulation of popular Hindi cinema
has not only inspired local filmmakers
but has set up a new kind of part of
circulation for Bollywood over the last
few decades as well and all of these
places this kind of new dis mapping from
Bombay to Karachi to Dubai to Nigeria
was very much a kind of what Ravi sundar
was called a pirate modernity where the
culture of the copy actually defines
both the production but also the
circulation of these sorts of films and
television programs so as we begin
considering what seems like a rather
dizzying assemblage of media
technologies of people of capital
I'm inclined to agree with
anthropologist William as well as
observation that there is really no
simple correlation anymore between the
space reality of cultural production and
the production of cultural space and as
we begin delving more and more into
these sorts of maps and circuits it
becomes clear that we are forced to
confront the limits of established Media
Studies paradigms that even today carve
up the space of media culture into
production reception or at best a
syncretic approach that takes us through
maybe a circuit of culture of sorts and
while some scholars have tried to shift
our attention to thinking about
television sales and distribution and
how that creates new circuits of
circulation I'm not convinced that these
established models are adequate and I'd
like to finish up this place suggesting
that maybe approaching all of this by
thinking about circulation as Brian
Larkin has done in the context of
Nigeria and that the c3 team here has
done in talking about credibility it may
be a way forward and what I'd like to do
in the rest of the conversation is to
perhaps consider how focusing on
circulation model hours might actually
inform and revitalize our field and
maybe even define a new kind of
problematic from which to then approach
the question of media globalization to
understand how one particular city in
the world is not only emerging as a
media capital but as actually
historically over time managed to
maintain its position as a dominant
media
alright so next up is Karolina Acosta Oh
zuru she's associate professor at Grady
College of Journalism and mass
communication at the University of
Georgia as a native Georgia and I'm
proud to see someone from my home state
here at MIT a native of Caracas
Venezuela Karolina teaches public
relations graphic communication and
cultural studies and she studies
telenovelas and their diverse audiences
I'm just going to show you first the
clip since some people don't know what
telenovelas are and so just show you how
this you don't need to understand
usually
it's time
that was the end of the episode actually
and yes and the episodes are really
important because those are the
cliffhangers
so telenovelas are all over the world
but some people think they're like soap
operas like the American soap operas
they are like soap operas they aren't
like soap operas they are like soap
operas because they're melodramatic
because they're every day of the week
they're not like soap operas because
they haven't and they have 120 episodes
maybe 300 episodes but they end the
American soap opera only ends 50 years
later or something like that and that
makes a huge difference in how people
relate to the characters in how people
relate to the stories and also
telenovelas in writing America are not
only in the afternoon blog they are on
primetime they're the most important
television genre in Latin America so let
me take you really quickly through this
very complicated telenovela world and
it's interesting because Bollywood has
sort of erased or blurred all these
distinctions between production and
consumption and here you're going to see
it's not as easy to blur that this this
limitations or the the limits between
production and consumption so see if
this thing works
2 billion is the global audience of
telenovelas 12 thousand hours are
produced every year they're watching
almost every region of the world they
are currently in a new face in the last
15 years
Maserati says calls it transnational
Guillermo Roscoe calls it mercantile but
really the emphasis is on sales there's
a there has always been this tension
between the cultural and the business
aspects of telenovela the business
aspect is eating the cultural aspect so
it's becoming sort of standardized and
we'll talk about what kind of standard
is being used increasingly not only
exclusively produced in Latin America
many countries in which telenovelas were
watch are not producing their own and
there's a
huge international market for the format
you know you sell the format and each
country produces it so telenovela they
tell in a world telenovela work has
become the empire of what we call the
remake and if you want to talk about
remakes we have to talk about her this
is the original Betty the Colombian
Betty Jo soy Betty La Fea and of course
we know that the world is full of
berries now including the u.s. berry
which by the way by the way
Ugly Betty is not a telenovela and so
this is the impart of the remake and is
this good look at all of them they all
have braces they all have eyeglasses
they all have they are all endearing
they have to be if not they're not Betty
so but let's go to lighting America
because Latin America and Spain you know
where people speak Spanish and
Portuguese in Latin America and Spain
these are the big markets still the
original market and these are the number
of telenovelas on the air in each of
these countries in March last month
okay so huge Ecuador who produces only
two telenovelas they have 37 on the air
so who are the major producers well
Argentina Brazil Colombia Mexico and
Venezuela have been traditionally the
producers Colombia is sort of a newcomer
in the last 10 years it has become huge
but we have also a new player and this
is a player that defines defies the
nation-state
Telemundo Telemundo is located in Miami
headquarters in Miami but it co produces
with Colombia RTI and it is a huge
player as we will see so how is the pie
divided in the Americas and Spain well
32% of telenovelas on the air come from
Mexico and this is something I want you
to start noticing this is how the pie
the whole pie in the Americas in Spain
works but if we look at the ad each of
these major producers they're also
consumers so what's in the air in
Argentina
this is what's on the air in Argentina
nothing from Venezuela something from
the rest but how are argentinian
telenovelas
they are producers so what do they
produce until the 1990s they underscored
a lot of the local they were I love them
because I thought they were they would
say a lot about the country not anymore
not anymore now the international market
is the goal to get that so now they're
trying to become standardized so not the
same they also have an accent issue the
accent in Spanish from Argentina is
something that is not widely acceptable
in other spanish-speaking countries so
they say they have a in oxidation and
sometimes they try to neutralize that
which is a shame I think but they have a
success they've become the big marketers
of youth-oriented telenovelas and they
sell lots and lots of formats there's a
huge producer called Chris morena that
sells lots of this look at Brazil open
television this is what they watch
Brazilian telenovela okay they are
fabulous ok it's the realism in
telenovela social cultural issues
political issues are part of the
telenovela is not just a love story the
context of the story is pretty important
characters are not Manicheans not goodie
goodie goodie goodie so good and they if
she's stupid and evil evil evil
with these eyebrow permanently like that
no not like that in Brazil and the
characters because they're not many key
and they evolve which is pretty nice in
a storyline high production values this
is this is like Hollywood the way they
produce it's beautiful remarks are rare
they produce new stories all the time
it's a very strong industry language
issue there in Portuguese so they're
dubbed in the rest of America of
lighting America and some people don't
like that they'd like to watch her
telenovela see in the original language
what about Colombia
this is what they watch in Colombia look
no Brazilian telenovela in Colombia
humor lots of it
characters are defined by a main trade
so sometimes they seem a bit cartoonish
but you can't take away yours I from
them
they're fun it's fresh the storylines
feel fresh they do not shy away from
showing local context and local problems
they've had telenovelas with lots of
drug issues drug trafficking the narco
traffic etc the obsession with plastic
surgery all that you can find what about
Mexico seventy-two percent is from
Mexico some from telemundo the end the
ones in telemundo shown on TV azteca
Televisa the big giant only shows what
they produce and a little bit from
Colombia also in TV Azteca none of the
rest mexican telenovelas are what you
think about when you think of
telenovelas very melodramatic moralistic
the characters disarray she is so
beautiful and naive she is ridiculous
and he's such a hunk but he's not
particularly intelligent and so and they
are like that all the way until the
happy end of course the evil ones will
pay the early crime and punishment and
punishment is huge context tends to be
unimportant the if these are underscored
by the Catholic principles they still an
awareness very predictable there's
always a big mansion with a huge
staircase and the big evil mother-in-law
will throw the protagonist down the
stairs so she loses her baby
always
they don't write new stories these are
remakes and remakes and remix in the
last 10 12 years Mexican telenovela sin
Televisa have all been remakes of old
telenovelas
what about Venezuela they have a more
balanced thing why because we're not
producing much that's why the pie looks
more balanced so telenovelas in
Venezuela if you take the Mexican model
melodrama and the Brazilian model
realism you can place all Venezuelan
telenovela somewhere in that continuum
some are very realistic
there was a telenovela I wrote a book
about a telenovela in which there was a
character that was a metaphor of ogre
child is the president so bad realistic
okay but there are also the melodramatic
ones the industry is heavily affected by
the country's political situation
president Chavez closed RCTV a huge
telenovela producer because they were in
the opposition the other Network - young
is terrified so there's a lot of
self-censorship going on and because our
city the south venetian has no local
competition so the industry is
completely deformed the local market is
deformed they win no matter what they
broadcast so this is it's a very sad
situation therefore it has lost terrain
in the international arena you can see
it by the other pie charts now so these
are this is sort of a summary of all the
pie charts just so you remember and here
are the telenovelas broadcast in the US
okay in the u.s. we have three major
players Univision Telemundo and Azteca
America and this is what we see half
almost half of the telenovelas are from
Mexico and these are of course the
makeup of Latinos in the u.s. 66.8% come
from Mexico and then the rest and if we
look at the census numbers for people
that are not born in the US that live in
the u.s. look at the major producers do
Mexico 1/3 of people who are not born in
the u.s. who live here are from Mexico
so it's a major player so if you are
going to decide in Univision and all
this name
it works who what kind of telenovelas
you're going to show the Hispanic
population you're going to think of the
what are they watching when they grow up
and this is what they watch when they
were growing up so they have been taking
this bottle since birth which is
Televisa and this is one edition offers
Univision offers just Televisa these are
the pie charts for Univision Azteca
America and Telemundo the major
competition is between Telemundo and
Univision so there's what we call the
Telemundo model okay what is it it has
two goals with Univision and the
international sales goal number one they
haven't achieved they have improved but
they are not close the big goal
international sales they're selling a
lot they co-produced with Colombia they
have all sorts of things they adapt all
novels they remake novels they have a
few original stories multinational cast
this is our these are the stories in
which the father has a Colombian accent
the mother has a Mexican ancestry accent
the daughter is Venezuela and the other
one is Ecuadorian this is like the
Organization of American States but at
least the protagonists one of them has
to be Mexican because they know that the
majority of the Hispanic population
comes from Mexico beauty is always over
talent in this model and they strive for
a neutral accent but frankly it sounds
most of the time like Mexico and a
little bit Colombian sometimes the
context of the stories is generic you
know somewhere in Latin America there's
this gorgeous farm or cattle ranch
we don't know where oh he went to the
city and it says city do that we don't
know where this is it doesn't matter the
only thing that matters is that the
girls have our show in their midriff
that's really important okay so this is
sort of the Telemundo
there's a Miami model also not made by
Telemundo by by the branches of the big
producers they have branches in Miami to
make them available the international
market goal is international sales all
remakes and rehashing you take three
stories just you cut them in little
pieces and you produce something new
with them or old it's very melodramatic
again the multinational cast and here
the neutral accent really sounds Mexican
and the vocabulary is very Mexican the
context of the storylines luxury they're
all in beautiful beautiful places these
two models are selling a lot elsewhere
in the international arena and the local
telenovelas producers Colombia Venezuela
Mexico Brazil Argentina are looking at
that and so we see this thing creeping
in so this is like the big panorama and
of course we will get to talk about this
later but I just wanted to mention that
there are these things that have
disrupted the traditional we produce you
consume telenovelas YouTube is the is a
huge archive of telenovelas and this is
the the people people love it the public
loves it if you are in Romania you can
watch what's going on in Colombia but
some of the producers don't like this so
Televisa has been you know arguing with
YouTube at a point they closed every
single account that had a Televisa
episode on YouTube they closed them all
so there were thousands of users with
accounts closed Venom easy own in
venezuela doesn't allow their content to
be seen outside of Venezuela so but the
people they don't take it they rebel and
I can show you later how oh sorry
well blogs of course and there are many
many blogs and there's also
vlogs in which they place the videos
hidden from the network's their chats
their message boards all these things
make them world a telenovela world
seemed a little bit smaller than it
really is it's really complex and big
and I know I've just given you like the
broad strokes but I guess with with
questions we can put this together thank
you very much thank you next up is
Jonathan Gray who's come comes to MIT so
often we're starting to think of him as
one of our locals he's an assistant
professor of communications and Media
Studies at Fordham University and soon
to accept a new position at my alma
mater the University of Wisconsin at
Madison he's the author of television
entertainment watching with The Simpsons
he's got a new book out on satire TV and
he regularly computes the group blog the
extra-textual up the content stream
without a paddle
okay so I wanted to talk to you about
some ethnographic research I did in in
Malawi last summer where I went largely
to look at how I'm media was consumed I
was particularly interested in how sort
of ideas of America or other countries
in particular South Africa or Nigeria
were were developed through media
consumption Malawi I mean I'll just say
a few words about Malawi and media
production talking about sort of three
industries of a film television and and
music and then talk a bit more about
consumption with film that the story is
quite quick most people I talked to said
that there were five Malawi and films
I couldn't confirm that number but the
mere fact that most people don't seem to
know of many other Malawi and films show
that is not much of a Malawi in a film
industry as far as television goes
there's one public broadcaster and
that's it and the public broadcaster
plays largely live elements so it's it's
partly si Spanish and showing a lot of
parliamentary proceedings Malawi
football games get played soccer sorry
games get played and then we get some
music videos and then from music there
is much more of a sort of vibrant level
of production Malawi and music has been
fairly successful in the region actually
not just in in Malawi and Malawi and
reggae particularly is done fairly well
although at the same time as as much as
it's done well when I say well what I
mean is it's circulated it's not at all
financially lucrative when I was there
one of the more successful Malawi and
musicians actually was was working in
the same town that I was at as a his day
job was a research assistant where he
got paid the equivalent of about ten
bucks a day so he needed to do that even
though he was one of the most the one of
the more famous musicians in the country
there are a few exceptions to that rule
but by and large it's not an industry
that pays a lot of money so what we have
in
in these sort of three main forms of
sort of media production is a business
that is not at all a big business
there's a very very little sort of room
for making a lot of money what you do
get though is a large amount of media
are circulating nonetheless largely
because it's it's coming in from other
countries in terms of just sort of
walking through first for those of you
don't know where Malawi is here we go
Malawi unfortunately became more famous
for the fact that Madonna wanted to a
doctor child there than anything else
but there we go in between Zambia
Tanzania and Mozambique and home to the
second largest lake in the continent um
I was doing my research in room P up in
the north and and lawanda there are two
main cities Blantyre in a long way and I
wasn't there but a large amount of the
population does actually live in the
outlying towns such as Rumpy and Lalonde
so as far as going back to those
industries as far as film goes there's a
lot of film that gets watched
particularly at what we call video shows
and here's an example of one with Arnie
adorning the Governator on the outside
video shows every town I went to had at
least one video show often multiple you
get in for about five Quatro which
translates to about three cents and how
it works is once you're in you can sort
of stay in and watch as much as you want
it's very interesting that it says
Calvin and Sheila videotaped library for
the best and latest movie because what I
was really interested in it was a lot of
the movies that were playing one not at
all the latest movies that we would
consider it was very much a sort of
flashback to the 80s and to the 90s with
a lot of Schwarzenegger Steven Seagal
jean-claude van Damme it seemed the only
exceptions the only time that I was
seeing movies that had been released any
time in around the last ten years where
when they had an african-american
actor at the center of them and largely
what was playing was either Hollywood
film or you were also seeing some
Nigerian films playing as well how
they'd work is you just outside there'd
be these this thing telling you what was
going on
none of these have been legally
purchased it was all it was old piracy
and pirate led and largely through V CDs
and through the two DVD collections that
have been put together and then they
would be watched and this is a sort of
average video show where you have this
this tiny television at the front and
then the the guy is sitting around only
guys
it wasn't deemed acceptable for women to
go into most video shows I heard that
this was different in the two main
cities but it certainly wasn't outside
so these were the kids watching and and
I'll get to this in a second this it was
also the video shows where you could
watch some of the television again not
much Malawi in television and there
wasn't too much interest I found in in
television in general outside of
television as something that played
movies so that the movie channels that
will come in by satellite from South
Africa started to get picked up by some
of the video shows that actually had a
dish or a lot of bars and particularly
bars that serviced some of the foreign
researchers that were there and so
television largely became a sort of a
medium that that sort of overflowed
outside of bars and a lot of what would
get washed with people standing watching
in the windows and there wasn't much
sort of interest in in series and indeed
I I saw only a few sort of recognizable
series while they're the only two being
CSI in Prison Break figure and then as
far as music you would get multiple
music sellers in each town at the and
this is an example of one from the mango
Chi which is one of the larger towns
where are you getting a lot of DVD
and P CDs and then also on CDs for sale
and the music I mean one of the things
that it actually led me to an interest
in Malawi was the the oddity that is
Dolly Parton's supreme reign in Malawi
Dolly Parton is pretty much as big as it
gets a rap hip-hop R&B are the sort of
key genres that have moved over from
America along with easy listening as
with the the popularity of Nigerian
soaps melodrama I think was particularly
popular and so you saw that through the
popularity of Celine Dion and so forth
country music was huge though and
particularly dolly there's a sort of
interesting story behind that because
I'd ask you know why is dolly so so big
and I continued was interested in this
large it was through a sort of quirk
where in around the 70s and 80s there
was a wave of missionaries who came in
to Malawi largely from the south and
they brought the country music with them
and then set up offices in a country
that largely has subsistence agriculture
and so it's set up something of a
middle-class because you can now work in
the offices rather than out in the
fields and so country music became the
music of the middle-class and somewhat
ironic given here it's seen as that the
they know the music of white trash and
so country music became a sort of sign
perhaps of of having you know made it of
course there's also you know for a
country where there's subsistence
agriculture is the job for many people
there's you know some nice shoehorning
of interest given what country music is
about at the same time but so what we
had was other than country music and
easy listening the which again was quite
often very old music from the sort of
70s and 80s the only sort of modern
music that you were getting was again
music largely by african-american
artists from from the US or music coming
in from neighboring countries and there
was a large amount of it so I mean what
I wanted to do here is just give you a
sort of a snapshot albeit very brief
because whereas I'm
seeming most people in this room some
sort of very basic working familiarity
with with what bully word or telenovelas
are as a concept I'm also assuming very
few of you have a basic working
knowledge with Malawi as evidenced by
the fact that one one person who I think
isn't here right now I continually asked
me about my research in Maui a very
different place but I thought that I
could then turn to some of the thematic
questions that Henry has posed but I
mean the one thing I would throw down
that I have a particular interest in is
is what all of this suggested in terms
of our continual fetishization and Media
Studies with the new you know Derek
compared as an excellent book could
rerun nation where he sort of reminds us
that a large amount of what's on
television in America is reruns and yet
we continually talk about everything
that's new and here I wasn't in Malawi
and a large amount of what was being
listened to what was being watched was
stuff that would have being considered
sort of old and old-fashioned and from
you know the sort of 80s and and
jean-claude van damme and and and not
you know the the modern ironic
reinvention of jean-claude van damme um
and so it made me I think there are some
interesting questions to be asked about
the fetishization of a new and how
studying media globally perhaps might
force us to look at the different
temporalities of media not just to pick
up on Austin's issues of circulation not
just spatial circulation but also the
sort of temporality of circulation what
moves where and how fast it moves and
what doesn't move there at all so that
for instance again as as much as music
moved around freely there was really no
rock whatsoever I played some u2 u2 for
someone it was the first time they'd
heard it and REM was completely unknown
and so forth and so there were very
different sort of paces and
temporalities of it and perhaps
can get into that more but at the moment
I just wanted to give her a brief over
so next up we have abdul rahman e cisco
a film echo it's a soccer sorry who was
born in Mauritania and raised in Maui
he's we've been watching his films
through the program in the last few days
Bamako is the most recent of them but
his work goes back to the 19 1990 short
film was ooh and the 2002 film waiting
for happiness and he's going to share
some of his thoughts for this thank you
I'm going to speaking in French because
I don't master English very well and the
lady sitting next to me is going to
translate she's my wife I find myself in
a special situation because I come from
a country a continent you know consumer
do yourself that's the consumer of all
these booty pads mush but that does not
put her Lea produces any images security
atrocities it's a sad situation for my
country the first book we laugh in a
larger way for the African continent
that's silly much they tell me why
because if the images are a mirror
imagine a Covanta to
hmm imagine you go every night in your
home we want to the horse and uber and
your bathroom we've work at her daughter
and you see somebody else in front of
you her situation she was sure she was
sure again it's a situation of a culture
position a real culture station and a
terrible one basically dylan touvell
mexican particle you because in
particular the Mexican telenovelas
Oh cute black people as equality lives
on African take the space in the
majority of African television a country
like Mauritania in the last ten years a
Pedrito field produced three films
twist the water sugar held the turns a
perfume and sadly I'm the director of
the three films crystal so it's a very
sad situation because we realize that
between the film's views there are that
themselves are hardly seen in the
country's gotta smash that the
population is watching other images
dollar from the the telenovela in the
form of telenovelas
consoie Mexican was yeah whether they're
Mexican of Brazilian who apparitions or
maybe a little bit Egyptian poorly PE
before the Arab foreign countries it
dogs a poker she deserted on the Casa
Mata so I would be in an administration
if I cut the consumer side the the
secret opened up a booth of what I would
call bad eating which your ma struggle
for it welcome the more you eat the more
you're hungry and you're gonna eat more
it's such a good year and it doesn't
really help you for help
reach your emotions why do you continue
eating come
was salty sauce is silly was it you know
like other drinks there are famous in
this continent possible not only in
Africa mwah that everybody drinks
support for smaller was so it's not
necessarily the best drink my syllabus
on teasing who soon but it's the drink
that imposes itself upon skeletal in
villa Ko so much African so I think that
telenovelas in the African Hollywood
producer more Bollywood a bit
differently
sorry political so much young are
products of consumption
come due to poor treaty exists or polish
Mars is like other products that exist
there not because to me those cotton
Africa also consumed lovely put it rapid
shows so Africa produces very few thing
except with dommage very few images may
not host your song on a heat recovery
but the other situation in my opinion
that I think is more grave G don't said
Polly feverish or dommage
the communica song in this purification
of image and communication yeah
continuity of s word is about there's a
Content that receives images it you know
put it back but that does not produce so
the DSR team or come see Circle T known
about the shows up after hear it Lord
there's a feeling as if this continent
does not have anything to share don't
have their plain food et so there is no
fluid exchange Moscow to Muir
Irish's cosmetical Lord okay and I
believe that all place has a richness to
transmit to another
mr. Commissioner pepper but this
transmission does not happen basket area
incandescent danced because already
there's a condescending Sula motion by
Malecha true of even on the notion of
culture as Korean cutie song default
because it's a culture that feels
stronger it Priya do mean players or so
forth and more that's dominating more it
feels stronger no no she remember to do
a little comparison but the notion of
culture is actually the opposite of that
like you to Cecilia party fusion
girls cultures what's particularly in
the other would not base on the pause
that we need to go and get me imperfect
in Africa reservoir but people that only
receive our Lord impossible but that the
other does not take the horizonte'
multi-party
does not have the feeling of
participating before Kumar and this
common effort feel our Constitution
which is the construction of humanity
and it's curious of one of the other
girl
Simone it will show that you love my
introduction and I'm here equities of to
collect but you listen to you listen to
what my colleagues will be postures and
that specialist passionate to me see
this is every qualification if necessary
I can answer questions
so as I said in the introduction what we
wanted to do here was give snapshots of
three very different local or four very
different local media scenes as they've
been impacted by the global flow or the
barriers to global transmission of media
that one of the things that struck me
just listening to this is the emphasis
on piracy as a mechanism by which media
travels across national borders for
better or for worse it seems like each
of you touched on this in one way or
another and I wonder if we could
elaborate a little more about the
relationship between legal and extra
legal or illegal systems of circulation
and how that's Elena Ellis our broadcast
but these days people just watch them on
YouTube I know that I'm doing right now
at case study of a telenovela produced
in Venezuela and when ABC on the network
has forbidden or has vetoed the
transmission on YouTube or any of these
video sharing places of this telenovela
so if you're in Venezuela you can watch
if you're outside says this video is not
allowed in your in the country where you
were trying to watch well people around
the world most of them Venezuelan sat
first said well hello and so there is
this guy and he's placing the videos in
a blog in a blogger blog you know and
there's a community around it and they
don't tell anyone they don't tell that
address to anyone I don't tell it to
anyone because I am watching there too
this is my object of study and now this
guy has included a chat on this blog so
anytime of the day you go into this blog
you can see not only the episodes and
he's only one evening behind let me tell
you okay
and you can see people chatting live
about what's happening and they have
produced a community they talk about the
country why are they saying this in the
telenovela oh it's probably
self-censorship because of this and this
they do a whole lot of analysis so it's
interesting because there is piracy in
that sense but there's also piracy in
Spain in particular there are lots of
people who go on the web and advertise
services that they will tape a
telenovela for you via satellite and
they sell it to you very expensive when
that happened the major producers like
Televisa decided to produce a Brigitte
versions of telenovelas you can buy a
whole telenovela on Amazon on 1495 and
it will not be the whole telenovela not
120 hours but 40 hours and that hasn't
worked people still go to YouTube and to
other places it's like people will want
to watch their thing no matter what at
one level it's useful I guess to just
start with thinking about relations
between the legal and the extra legal
for instance just very recently in
almost - as if to coincide with this
global convention celebrating a decade
of globalization the MPA is set up an
office in Bombay to figure out ways to
monitor and possibly clamp down on the
kind of piracy that happens there and
even more recently there were full page
ads taken out in newspapers
english-language newspapers in
particular warning filmmakers in Bombay
away from trying to adapt the recent
Brad Pitt film the one hand which he
ages backwards what's it called the
Benjamin Button film right so it's it's
okay but that kind of relationship
between the legal and extralegal seems
not only I thought it doesn't seem very
productive at one level because one of
the things to recognize right away that
in cities across Asia across parts of
Africa and even in Latin America
a significant way in which so-called
legal media circulate are actually
through cultures of the copy so in many
ways for instance would say early
television the way in which cable
expanded into homes across Asia was
through local neighborhoods young men
stringing cables across rooftops which
enabled the kind of spread of cable TV
in ways that would not have been
possible otherwise diaspora culture if
you were to think about that diaspora
culture is a culture of circulation and
so it seems instead of thinking about
the sort of legal extralegal binary it's
perhaps much more useful to think about
the ways in which these two realms
actually inform each other and the way
in which for example fans of a firm
music director will at the same time
that they're actually setting up
BitTorrent sites to circulate songs
online we'll also go to the local
neighborhood pirate and tell him to
remove the songs syndrome care of pull
series of their favorite from music
director office shelves because they
want that for music directors CDs to
sell more so it's a much more
contradictory and sort of ambivalent
relationship to the legal and extra
legal than this kind of discourse of
piracy allows us to acknowledge yeah I
mean I might jump in on that and that it
would be important to point out that
there would be very little media moving
around malawi if not for piracy I mean
take movies for instance there are there
are no official movie cinemas and even
in the cities in Malawi this is a very
poor country that the multinational
corporations that make a lot of the
media that gets pirated these
corporations just don't aren't
interested in Malawi they can't make
money from Malawi because they can't
charge or they won't charge low enough
and so movies in in Malawi particularly
moved through piracy and through piracy
alone and a larger amount of music moves
that way too
so you know on one level you know one
sort of has to throw off a sense of of
caring about you know the poor plight of
Time Warner and so
forth very early on the other hand I
would point out that this is the curse
that that really kills Malawi and media
production in and of itself when I was
there almost every day there would be a
newspaper article about Malawi's
attempts to try and get better laws to
work against piracy not because they
cared about the now sort of making sure
that the Disney and so forth we're
making yet more money but so that local
Malawi and musicians could actually make
some kind of money rather than having to
work as you know research assistants for
for farm projects looking at HIV because
they there as much as they're famous
they they're there their productions
basically just don't make the money
there so I mean I think there are really
sort of two very different forms of
piracy there the one that sort of makes
media move in the first place but but
then also the the attention to the the
piracy that actually stops production
and makes it very hard for many people
to actually go into making media at any
level I would like to see two words
about piracy in Africa some that looks a
bit like the consumers of a joint that
we look for but not the producer in the
desert
as it was said like you know hundreds of
thousands of pirated films are in Africa
like slums our Canadian Air yo man how
do we so enough acai to see it at the
same time but these are hundreds of
thousands of products that were made
outside so this is about parking and
it's difficult to trace where the
producers machine the majority of these
films come from China myself when I went
there China to show my film bama cause I
didn't want woody it was a Friday and
Monday was already pirated and mr. sharp
I think the country process with the
cover much nicer than our French cover
of the verdict seems very stream so it
means that it's a real industry
something that's been thought through
I don't you saw summit Russia that
that's profitable to people that are
never touched yeah not a circular so
bigger
there is another legal circulation of
films luteum what I'd like to talk to
that I think is very serious
sushant it delivers Africa it's some
African television public television
Huell it's a balance you know from of
showing advertisement instead of
advertisements show telenovelas and it's
actually just to fill the time spaces
you're quite pretty sure no condom
because there's no local production or
nothing slaughtered for that time sorry
if usually course a console without
really thinking of the consequences and
here i think there's a real the mission
of from political in a country where you
have sixty to seventy percent starin
know enough about no television
facilitates is a unicorn but TV
television is a school because it you
become so the screen is the school see
to your hope you do show so bad yeah
so if you fill it up with with content
that's not some awesome then it's a bad
school one of the things that I did want
to add which your comments part was when
we talk about piracy in this legal extra
legal sort of if you keep falling into
that line of discussion it really leads
us to ignore the fact that cultures of
circulation are also cultures of
production and I recognize that we need
to make this very very context-specific
but the ways in which certain parts of
the world are able to actually enter
into an engagement with different kinds
of emerging media technologies be there
productions of VCDs be there subtitling
of dvds within a day of its release in
some part of the world and the way in
which it then gets circulated it's not
the circulation that needs to be thought
much about broadly in terms of
circulation of not just the artifacts
the cultural products themselves but
also of certain kinds of skills and
abilities to produce and remake certain
kinds of media technologies that are
part of the discussion so one of the
questions that your comments part was
when you think about cities like on or
Legos or even Johannesburg and the kinds
of circulation that
happen through these regional media
centers isn't aren't those evidence that
there are maybe other things that are
happening in the landscape of media
production in Africa not just about
receiving in circulation but actual
production that I think Nigeria South
Africa our particular examples could you
show you know that have an enormous
production queuing one shows which is a
good thing
let's go wash it was currently shown me
was about me because at least at the
mirror that I was talking about earlier
there supposedly at least again people
can see themselves projected you can see
that their father can be the the thief
or the doctor don't ya so at least the
society is better told to itself Lanisha
relatively particulate nigeria is a
particular country Memphis initially off
for the diversion in the same way that
they make the the products did they make
the tires of the cars that you can buy
for if you don't know without much means
it's pretty easy that you can use this
emotion about you and it works in the
cars but the quality is not the same
shikaka Donatella domiciliary also you
see sir and I think one homes it's also
that but it's a less it's a lesser
problem it's very important that there's
a local production so click follow up on
this could you sale something about the
systems of circulation that shaped the
flow of your films to the world you come
from very different kind of film culture
than the 90
one clearly but how how are you
succeeding in getting your films I went
to study film in the Soviet Union came
up a book coup d'etat and that took me a
long time you see a fortune in authority
marshal you see more but that also set
up my relationship with image and cinema
don't you fear sacrifice anymore so I do
a certain kind of which is not which
does not have a big pop it's not very
popular
no we're gonna see anybody like some of
some independent films but I think that
as long as there's one person who's
interested in shoes that's interested in
one thing with one symbol for me that's
a lot so I consider myself lucky that I
exist more because of I'm an oil-water
writer director but the real frustration
is when we make films and often film has
very little chance to get seen in your
own country 2-0 sector but yet you used
actors of your country this was the
story of the country yep a ducati track
but there's no there's no screening
rooms or theaters to show and there's
much thing
like to permit myself to say if I give
if I gave my film to television of my
country
you so come up with the money to promote
then they can ask me to pay for it
to show my film King me whether it's
myself
yes situation sincerity and that's the
reality don't see so and I pour for my
three scums so we're very saddened when
we live this kind of station or
circumpolar Saji and we know that we
cannot change it in one day what today
the film should kill or maybe pass take
the example of my last film that had
more success than the previous ones
it was got a lot of press and media
because it was at the Cannes Festival so
I had a French distributor of ammunition
who sold the film internationally as
well as in the States
the distributor the New Yorker film's
distributor Keanu [ __ ] me that just
closed down so now it's difficult to get
the film Lena it's just to show the
vicious agile
this films are of course you see the
shirt you follow this to be shows how
fragile the people who are distributing
this kind of films are in this in so
which is an issue that cropped up across
a number of the presentation clearly art
films or independent films travel
differently around the planet than
melodramas or
films or music coalition so what role
the why do some genres seem to generate
the global flow whether it's the action
films that are John film the film
productions Julie you've talked about I
think in the case of telenovelas there
are several factors that make it so
well-received globally one is melodrama
melodrama is universal and you know it's
been used even in our coverage of the
Olympics how do we cover the Olympics
now we we make it melodramatic
you know we create the hero myth in
every one of our athletes you know that
it's a Cinderella story the Cinderella
story in particular which is repeated in
many telenovelas resonates in many
cultures because the face of poverty
around the world many times has the face
of a woman and so it resonates elsewhere
in addition to that there is what mr.
Sasaki just said this is a very cheap
way to feel the airwaves when you buy a
telenovela you have material for one
hour for every day of the week for at
least four months it could be four to
eight months cheap so that's another
another reason especially in Eastern
Europe when I went through the
transition this was an easy way to fill
the airwaves and now of course there is
the not the consumption now there is the
addiction because they are addictive
because people think oh no they're not
you know only oh I've heard so many
people they say only stupid people
consume them because they are of massive
consumption and massive deprecation too
but I want to any of you I challenge you
to sit through two episodes of a
telenovela two episodes and then you
tell me if you don't want to know what's
gonna happen
and I've tested these every semester
with my own students and it's amazing so
they have something in them and I think
also that telenovelas
what are they you know there's a famous
venezuelan writer who once said
telenovelas are the spectacle of
sentiments of emotions and that's
universal emotions and sentiments and
this is why people identify with this
strange stories that can be some of them
very strange all over the world so
that's for telenovela I think Bollywood
has a lot of melodrama - mm-hmm it does
but I'm not again I'm a little
uncomfortable with this because it seems
like we're talking about why certain
genres travel and let's say we take say
different kinds of television shows and
why one television show gets bought by
one for one part of the world and not
another but it seems like in hindsight
we can if we talk about the notions like
cultural proximity and that's why this
particular show was worked in this
market in hindsight we can discern some
sort of a mysterious correspondence and
pretty much any sort of media and
culture relationship I mean why
Bollywood films clicked or Bombay cinema
clicked in 70s and 80s Nigeria one way
to explain it the brand larkin does is
to talk about notions of parallel
modernity that certain changes that were
happening in youth culture and in other
parts of Nigeria resonated with that but
to speak about these sort of
universalistic categories of emotion and
melodrama and so on again I'm not sure
how far it gets us in thinking about
global media flows and maybe Jonathan
can add a little bit here about the ways
in which industry executives justified
the decision to buy insyndicate and
circulate certain kinds of media
products rely on these sorts of
assumptions about some correspondence
between what would work here and what
can work and thinking about the way in
which we've talked about media
localization and how television and film
circulate around the world
maybe notions of cultural proximity and
not really that useful at the end of the
I don't know I mean what might my first
my first sort of response when I when I
was in Malawi is to to look at how much
melodrama there seemed to be across
difference if media so that again a lot
of that the sort of Celine Dion I can't
live without you lyrics which by the way
we're a crossed over regardless of
gender to but so it wasn't as coded as
as feminine as it tends to be in America
um but at the same time I then started
to find that there were all these
exceptions out there so that I mean a
lot of the the songs that are really
popular from within Dolly's you know and
they're all there but a lot of the songs
that are popular they're actually a lot
more sort of they're not about not just
about you know I can't live without you
they're there some of her more sort of
complex interesting lines and then again
with the the interest in a lot of
african-american produced music and and
and movies or any miss sort of movie
about Africa seem to circulate too so
that you know the Curious Case of
Benjamin Button would go absolutely
nowhere in the average video show but
Hotel Rwanda could be found pretty much
every roadside stop where they were
selling stuff and so I mean often that
there needed to be a reason to be
interested in it but I was finding all
these exceptions to this sort of
supposed rules of what travels well and
does doesn't travel well and I mean as I
suggested earlier dolly is a perfect
example of that that it there's a sort
of sense of happenstance that sometimes
perhaps we we're looking for the sort of
easy rules about what travels to where
we tend to sort of lose out on a lot I
think of sort of Tim havens does does
work on the global media marketplace and
he talks about what's his phrase for
that
no yeah industry lore where he just
spent so these assumptions that things
don't play well so that like
traditionally Hollywood has felt that
the rest of the world isn't interested
in african-american shows even though
there's absolutely no real data to back
that up I remember growing up as a child
moving around the world when I was in
Singapore the facts of life was huge in
Singapore and Malaysia and it was
marketed solely as a as a as Trudy a 2d
or Trudy into Dee's show and and she was
at the center of it and she was the hero
of it and and yet that goes completely
against industry law lore that would
normally say no no no don't put in that
african-american character because the
rest of the world don't want to hear
about so there are the dangers of
finding of trying to find those those
simple rules and the one of the things
that was interesting that emerge from
the entire media convention was this was
right around the time that Slumdog was
getting more awards and leading up to
the Oscars and so of course all the
panel's featured someone from Fox
Searchlight and all the questions were
about how can we replicate this and of
course everybody was trying to come up
with reasons for why it worked across
the world why it would in this market
and work somewhere else but the
happenstance seems to be crucial because
the one thing that seemed guaranteed is
every sales agent every distributor who
attended the convention did see at the
end of the day that they will now look
twice and think twice before rejecting
something that had anything saltation to
do with it
so to that extent perhaps these sorts of
correspondences do work but beyond that
I'm not sure notions of genre melodrama
or kung-fu action cinema why they travel
to one part in another they need to be
much more locally specific like the work
you're doing in Mohave and we need to be
much more careful about that so I think
that there is a principle of addiction
No Mas
but that's explainable because of the
mass quantity
when you send the same thing most again
and again all the time and on top
there's also the melodramatic side limo
so I love that emotion is there this is
a suffering of these people were school
regardless of how much richer than
yourself they are is only because
they're in this big houses and beautiful
houses you don't sue but inside them
their sufferings conceptually the
resolution and I think that is something
that interests people it's not me
something I've studied based for it
Lifford
but I consider ability mushrooms that
there's an openness to the matter my
wife was telling me earlier in my ear
and it repeated any to observe over the
time where the Japanese telenovela was
very popular it's less now because
they're not as much visible this still
exists actually it's European television
and a lot of people know them by heart
so another character is really well so
and I wanted to ask you about the scene
in Bamako that has Danny Glover in it
and what his role is in the production
and what you intended to comment on in
that scene maybe you could share a
little bit of the scene with the crowd
in double code is a moment that lasts
about four minutes that's a film within
a film in the courtyard there are people
watching television this one like they
do every night so it's we're getting of
a film a spaghetti western because you
should turn a moment that I have found
shot myself with Danny Glover because
the idea of helping financially to make
the film he co-produced of course if he
first some helped in the sense of
towards the film yeah most offices
across the West there and then I had the
sequel idea of the sequence in which I
wanted to film my friends as actors so I
asked Danny Glover know if you could
come and that's how he participated
Samant diverse job the fine it's also
shows in Bamako that tell television as
a moment of evasion a runaway space for
people in the family where there's 20
people that live together but that leave
maybe there's not five books available
so we go towards physics to see
something that's more accessible I know
going in our family servant workers that
work in the house to give people the
help okay got a little villa I see you
much yeah follow the telenovelas brother
the Brazilian of Mexicans
it should move cynic white house but
follow them without knowing a single
word and it was really per member per se
because they don't even speak French or
any other language party but they will
never miss as she said and don't have
she said so we do book shows so it's
because that's what TV means a lot of
things that there's a need that's
created by it okay
I promise that the audience would get a
chance to ask questions we've left this
opening segment go a little long but I'm
eager to see questions from the floor
there are two mics down there and if
anyone has a question to get us started
if not we'll buy us some time by asking
another oh please
hi-yah um I wanted to hear a little bit
more about co-production in these
different regions there's this idea that
if we co produce then we're broadening
the market and but then we get these
cases where you have that you know with
the movies with Spain you always have
that Cuban movie with an old
revolutionary anarchist uncle or
whatever that just what is he doing
there and you know that has totally
changed the look co-production policies
have changed the aesthetics of much of
Latin American film I wonder how that is
affecting telenovelas and what happens
and I don't know in Africa what the
reality of co-production is I am
speaking from Costa Rica which is my
case our situation is that we
co-producer we die also but but it's
related to financing and we just have to
deal with our monster neighbors because
in fact we took we're talking now about
Brazil and Mexico and it sounds like
Latin America is producing so much but
at least in film 90% of all thumbs made
in Latin America from the very beginning
have been made in Mexico Brazil and
Argentina and that's it so okay comment
on question but co-production well
co-production is what the Telemundo
model it's not only theirs but they are
the ones who have made it very
successful why do they cope reduce
because it's very it's cheaper to have
actors placed in Colombia where you pay
Colombian salaries okay instead of
Miami's how
so and also you use all this actors
there of course you save the big bucks
for the big stars which are those
protagonists that at least one of them
has to be Mexican okay you're very right
about the issue of films I think
Colombia just like it is coming now has
come up in telenovelas has come up also
in film it is sort of the the new kid on
the block Venezuela
just like it is lagging in telenovelas
now it is lagging in films even the
oppressor and Chavez has created film
Villa to produce films and he has given
money even to Danny Glover
to produce films in Venezuela of course
these films have to be with a particular
point of view that's quality that way I
think there are other there are
countries in which the only way they can
play the production game is by
co-producing so there's a model right
now in which the Miami model is being
used co-produced with countries like
Panama the Dominican Republic so they
make one telenovela in the Dominican
Republic in which the protagonist the
antagonist are this multinational cast
of heavy hitters everyone else is from
the Dominican Republic and that's the
only way they can produce a telenovela
and let me tell you the Dominican
Republic is a huge consumer of
telenovelas countries that do not
produce telenovelas in Latin America
tend to be the largest consumers
actually so they have tried this model
in the Dominican Republic
recently in Panama and we have to see
how it sells abroad to me the issue is
that now the model is that melodramatic
model is a model that tells the same
story with little variations but it's
it's not saying anything telenovelas can
say a lot and there's lots of research
about telenovelas being very effective
in health campaigns
in Venezuela extremely effective in the
political discourse also in Brazil but
the model that is being sold abroad the
model that is circulating with success
is a model that really sells very well
but doesn't say much
my case is a bit particular so path is
peptide speakin general ask because I
live in France octopus that produces my
films political she knows monofin fancy
is one of the European countries that
have a politic of financing films that's
quite from incredible don't associate a
copepod you have a cafeteria because I
have a production that copa dos Manos
the Commission have the advantage of the
finances or Commission's the telenovela
free can't become a sonido like for
example about the African telenovelas
starting to exist example you until in
Villa cote ivoire so for example they
are telling novellas in Ivory Coast West
Coast cellphone said not to live because
it's in French so it's Feud and all the
french-speaking African countries in AXA
for Boonton of a soul and others are
made it in Burkina Faso you come on so
cheesy the doctor yeah yeah and they
also start to use actors from Ivory
Coast or Molly you don't kolonko most
about the petite coalition so for those
starts covered is having small
co-production with each other if you saw
our secret to subdivision the Busan
people seemed but when ice know that all
this becomes more and more possible
development come back what did yeah
because
development of Africa and the daily
struggle Lujan come on a condition where
many people are starting to count on
themselves
no not on polish toast agenda so we
don't know long wait as much time ten
AMISOM that we see in many domains you
see one memc traditional features but
are also same Ivan though they're very
very few films that are produced um so
I'm actually curious for with the first
two provocations that Henry brought up I
was wondering if we could push them
together a little bit because as when
you talked about the necessity of having
sort of a cultural specificity and baked
into that it seems there's this question
of not like a technologically
determinist platform specificity but so
the sort of regulations and structures
and protocols that surround the
encounters of media as it moves and how
that changes what content circulates and
then how that content in turn shapes the
sort of flows and spaces of transmission
so I was wondering if you guys could
talk a little bit about how I guess if
we have to fall into the legal extra
legal by an area how the different modes
of circulation effects may be what
medias what kinds of media circulates
what telenovelas for instance if they're
the same as the ones that are being sort
of pushed outward by the national
broadcast producers and if the different
kinds of say fan engagements affect how
that media is then sort of processed and
used
that's a one way to maybe start thinking
about it is to say let's going back to
the co-production aspect of it is
co-production immediately it reminds us
that state institutions are very very
vested in it and that there are certain
kinds of cultural policy positions that
shape what kinds of co-productions are
allowed or not allowed and
co-productions also remind us that every
core production is an encounter of
translation between different kinds of
production cultures and the built-in to
that is also what finally then gets to
what finally then circulates across the
world so speaking in just in terms of
the bollywood context one of the dangers
of using the term bollywood even though
it allows gives us some specificity in
this panel
it actually erases a lot of other
boundaries about what actually is
circulating so the first mapping that we
did say from Bombay to London to LA that
mapping only suggests that only a
certain kind of Bollywood cinema
circulates because the diasporic market
in the UK and the US has been
constructed in a very specific way over
the last 15 years which gets complicated
even further by the fact that within the
US the trajectory of South Asian
American South Asian migration means
that certain model minority discourses
fit in to the way in which consumption
of Bollywood happens which in turn
filters all the way back to Bombay which
then leads to further sorts of industry
locating sediment that are saying okay
these films work let's just keep pushing
these films out but then if we look at
another mapping another historical
moment say from New Delhi the central
government making certain decisions
about their geopolitical ties and then a
certain kind of melodramatic films
actually traveled into Russia and into
Eastern European former socialist bloc
countries and then when we moved to say
the African context the much more angry
young man firms of the seventies of a
popular star Amitabha
those are the ones that that were
traveling around so those are the sorts
of examples that come to mind which
remind us of the ways in which the
National continues to play a role in
these kinds of transnational
circulations and the way in which state
institutions continue to regulate the
ways in which certain content and
certain kinds of forms get to move
around the world and not others I'm not
sure that even begins to tackle that
question but I think it also shows the
degree to which we need to study who the
pirates are and I mean I can understand
why a lot of the times people don't want
to because we are the Pirates the the
forerunner of this did a lot of burning
while I was in in Malawi but I or
because we don't want to draw attention
to them but with the example I gave of
how country music became popular the
answer to that question that I kept on
asking was basically who were the
Pirates how did it get there um and so I
think there's still there needs to be a
lot more study of who's taking these
things from from culture to culture and
place to place what are the interests
there and what are the what if this sort
of what kind of interaction they have
with the people there too
for instance in Malawi I also noticed
that the Bollywood was almost nowhere to
be seen
there's a long sort of tense
relationship between Malawi ins and
between the Indian population and in
India that I think when I talk to people
was partly responsible again there was a
sense there that they didn't want to
watch Indian media because they didn't
like Indian people and so I think
sometimes just asking the questions of
who brought the media and and what are
the how do what do we think about these
people and what did they what else do
they bring with them starts to open up a
lot of a lot of answers to other
questions there is this question about
okay so if you if people watch Italy
know
on YouTube or somewhere else if that's
already sold to their country will they
watch it we just have in the telenovela
on YouTube increases or decreases the
potential the sales potential of that
telenovela now about this question to
several people in the business and you
can't find one answer something no no it
increases sales no no it decreases the
sales so while I just told you that
story about banana soon in Venezuela and
told you sir about Televisa Telemundo
for instance they put every day their
episode of Dona VAR URL rostral and a
lien they put it on the web for everyone
to watch and on everywhere in the last
two months has been the most widely so
telenovela in the world and they have
the episodes there so there is that
question about eastern and Avila
watching a thing we do on computers or
if we have the choice to watch it as a
family at home
is that how we watch so the patterns of
consumption I think we can't forget them
when we think about all these concepts
that are so blurred now distribution
consumption circulation production all
those into one quick additions there's
no reason to assume that the industry
professionals aren't talking to the
pirates I mean so one example is there
is a wheeler-dealer I guess is the best
way to describing who lives in Boston
but who travels regularly to Chile
Poland Germany parts of China and so on
just looking for fan communities small
subculture of fan communities of say
Shahrukh Khan a Bollywood star for
example and what he does is he goes
there he hangs out with them encourages
them to form a little Club or an
association and actually gets them
subtitling writes things of that sort
organized screenings and then goes back
to Bombay and talks to the you know the
legal distributors and the producers and
say here maybe I've discovered a little
market here why don't we strike a deal
I'll get this Commission and we'll start
say pushing a few films into that market
so we need to break
really need to complicate this extra
legal extra legal thing there's
absolutely no reason to assume that
these different spaces are not already
in dialogue with each other they are but
that's what I think the kind of
ethnography that Jonathan is describing
would help us get to get into and
understand these sorts of networks and
dialogues much more so I guess when we
talk about global media you think about
barriers but essentially we don't really
see one based on distribution or really
I guess you could say culture but
instead we see one based around the
language and Cavatina started off by
saying that if you just watched media
you really don't need to know the
language to understand what's going on
depending the situation of course but as
we said during his talk when the media
is distributed it also teaches people
how to produce and essentially create
their own works so I wonder if there's a
sort of conflict between the dispersal
of global media based on the language
and how that's affected the development
of media in different areas around the
world
fansubbing comes to mind I mean but
you're right that language angiocath
certain kinds of markets do impose
certain boundaries around this but that
seems to be where it begins as in small
sorts of fansubbing activities where
there is one very popular website a
youtube channel set up by a woman and
it's called SRK paulina I mean a fan of
Shahrukh Khan and this woman has learned
hindi learned to subtitle every single
thing that Shahrukh Khan appears in from
advertisements to TV shows to films and
that's where it begins but yes there's
no getting away from the fact that
language organizes certain kinds of
flows and even within certain kinds of
countries especially say South Asia
given the number of languages that there
are at least seven eight viable film
industries in South Asia at this point
in time but only in the Hindi language
Bollywood films get privileged as the
global media product the rest are still
at best regional or maybe trans local if
you want to if people want to be
charitable but there's a politics to the
way in which certain language television
and I think in the digital digital age
fansubbing seems to be
multi-generational and you can reproduce
the thing without diminishing the
quality of the original so when I was in
Shanghai a year ago I met a reporter
he's been covering the Pirates there and
what she said was that it took less than
24 hours for an episode of Prison Break
to air on American television and to be
translated into Cantonese or one of the
other major Chinese languages and it's
done by teams of amateur fans who want
access to that content it spreads out to
the inter land via the computer and then
the Cantonese version gets translated
into a different Chinese language that
may deal with a smaller language
population and again teams are waiting
to do that so it's a 48 hour or 72 hour
process as opposed but the flow of media
is you know there would have been a time
when language was an absolute barrier to
that and it seems to me that it's now
multi stomp but
you know as long as you have digital
organization and digital reproduction
it's it's less complicated a problem
than it might have once been where as
culture may be you know cultural
affinity may be much more crucial than
language I think in the end in
determining what what circulates I mean
I guess to follow up with that I mean if
you've been on the Internet in in a year
it's obvious that audiences have taken
off the effort to help the distribution
of media but in terms of production has
the language barrier really solidified
certain areas of production enough that
there hasn't really been a flow between
those areas in terms of something on
genre or just general general elements
of the actual production instead of the
perception I don't know I think
telenovelas are you know translated and
dubbed in almost every language in the
world I think an interesting case have
found it's actually inside the United
States because for a while there
telemundo had closed caption in spanish
in english of its telenovelas and then
suddenly they stopped because of the
financial crisis it's a recent event
interface and and there was this uproar
and i have a blog and in my vlog people
were writing like crazy in english what
happened and so there is this other blog
in which there is a group of 10 people
who are all over the united states and
they every day that each one of them is
in charge of one telenovela and they
write recaps in english every episode
every day of every telenovela broadcast
in the united states and all these
people that were in the outdoor are now
flocking there so they watch the episode
and then they read without understanding
it and then they go and read the recap i
don't know the other thing is that I
mentioned how in Latin America some
people say I don't
to watch Brazilian telenovela because
their job and I'd like my telenovelas in
my in my language in my native language
I always find that interesting as
interesting as some of my students when
they say they don't stay don't go to see
foreign films because they have
subtitles and when I tell them in my
country every Hollywood film has
subtitles it's like they've discovered
some new line or something like wow
really
well lighting Americans everywhere in
the world
people are watching tonight all right I
see their dog dope with subtitles so
it's not a big deal
although it seems to be so I mean I
would just add to the I mean in Malawi
there is no fence I'll being going on
there aren't many people on line to
begin with and there isn't the resources
for for even officials of subtitling so
then I mean linguistic barriers there
are very hard I mean
Malawi shares way more of a border with
Mozambique than it does with either
Zambia or Tanzania and yet you don't
hear much about about media from
Mozambique in Malawi because Mozambique
has a different linguistic background
both in terms of local dialects but also
in terms of having been a French colony
instead of English colony and and so I
mean there's a very hard and fast divide
that as much as we can get excited by
how fan and should get excited about how
fans and audiences are bridging some of
these divides that then might have some
sort of trickle over effect or
production it is important to remember
that there many countries in the world
that where the finances for such things
are just not there
I wanted to add an example on the
languages which is clearly shows to
change I think there things are changing
for example there's a table called
Africa Africa Africa below million bases
in Mali come on Sam okay the silly
Ghanaian that started to show Danny and
Jose but subtitled in French there's no
hey God and so people watch them busker
you should focus again my yarn
fedka see Africa yes other African
countries so there's a sneeze this is I
stop seeing stories that way you can
recognize yourself in them
major pesky foot Politico secure but I
think we also have to talk about killer
John University trailer popular weekly
marshes that people have the capacity to
create their own language with the
images that they see some come for
summer without necessarily understanding
Spanish Kasasa prefer and I think that's
very reported capacity did you see
capacity of Oscar they cannot be true
the city won't deduct what's going to
happen because of them because of the
language of cinema is immensely
beautiful and for me that's the most
interesting a factor one of the themes
that keeps appearing in the discussion
that has appeared in the discussion this
afternoon is what we might call the
tension between the global and the local
and one of the things that struck me as
I thought about the discussion was I
thought back to a film scholarship in
the pre-digital age when one of the
primary issues for a number
of years was like what was that was the
problem of the major media producers
especially the United States so flooding
local markets with their own material
that local filmmakers had very little
chance and as some of you surely know it
was an era in which in which a number of
national organizations and even
legislators began to create limitations
on the amount of on the amount of
American media as a number of American
films that could be shown in particular
countries now what I'm what I'm curious
about is whether or not there's some
version of this now in the in the age of
global media that is to say isn't it
possible to imagine that what you've all
been describing is a circumstance in
which it is no longer the case that
there is one major media nation that is
flooding the market but that there are a
relatively smaller number a relatively
small number of media major media
producers Bollywood is one the
telenovela consortium is one American
media continues to be a dominant thing
and that these three of and there might
be a few others but these three or four
sources coming to dominate global media
as well and and and and flooding out the
possibility that certain kinds of local
or or or or national media enterprises
would be that national and local media
enterprises might be inhibited or or
restrained partly because of the fact
that the that that the global media that
is now finding a much easier way to
spread itself even leaving aside the
issue of piracy which increases the
problem in certain certain ways creating
a situation in which even more intensely
than in the era of American dominance of
media we're going to have a relatively
small number of sources creating
essentially the entertainment for the
entire globe does this seem like a
ridiculous fear or or something to worry
about I think to some degree there it's
the sort of Coke Pepsi war right that if
Coke and Pepsi can convince you that you
have to choose Coke or Pepsi you know
they both of them of one in the long run
and and in if it was if the issue used
to be American dominance versus local
that's one thing whereas I think what at
least what I saw in Malawi and of course
this was assisted by the fact that
there's very little local production
outside of the realm of music is that
the the the major the the the countries
that do flood Malawi with their media
they people can then play them off
against each other so if you resent
American presence and certainly a lot of
the people I talk to did resent my
American presence and so their response
to that was to watch more Nigerian media
or people would feel that Nigerian media
was too outlandish and that dealt with
rich craft and they didn't think that
that was right and so they watched lots
of American media and so what you you
have there is Nigerian media and
American media have sort of become the
Coke Pepsi battle where Malawi and media
and the possibility of Malawi sort of
producing something in between sort of
Falls up by the wayside now I mean that
might be very peculiar to Malawi given
that there isn't the money to to produce
or sort of rival but I at the same time
suppose that there probably many other
countries like that around the world
where the sort of war that goes on
between these sort of global media
industries leads the sort of local
production totally by the wayside right
that's what that's the issue that I
think is of concern it's useful to
remember that American dominance was
never complete or never quite spanned
the entire globe there are many other
industries that were not so much
resisted but really there was they had
their own trajectories of influence and
so on but you're right the point you
make is one that Michael Curtin has made
recently as well and thinking about
relations between media capitals instead
of continuing to think about whether one
media capital dominates the world but I
mean perhaps public access television in
the u.s. is a good example of how local
media production is it's increasingly
difficult to do
okay yeah all right well thank you so
much for coming it's been a great
discussion
you